is can
you turn a hoe into a housewife
but in order to answer this question i
think we got to define what is a hoe
so i want to hear from the guys
what do you guys think a hoe is
going chris
to me
[Music]
what i would call her is
a girl that's
been run through
that you know about like if you don't
know she if you don't know she hasn't
been running through then like you can't
really you don't know on it but once you
know and it's out there like
she just has that name like you know
that you have a chance
what is what is ran through you like is
there is it a number or is it like
yeah but
if you know somebody that smashed or you
know a couple people that smashed okay
okay that's a hell and obviously like a
number if it's
like relative to age isn't it but if
we're talking like
near the hundreds
oh hundreds yeah like oh gosh do you
know do you know girls that are near the
100s
i do i'm like i don't know anyone that's
slept with that many people
well that's a girl anyway you shouldn't
be near that but if you need this then
so so if you know like one friend that
slept with her she's a hoe
it depends on the friend okay there's
certain people you're like yo like he
smashed
okay
so like if you don't rate him
yeah if you don't really so if you don't
rate him and he's been there you're like
you have to be a hood
like if he's ugly or something or what
what do you mean like if the guy is ugly
or like his value yeah like i think i
mean it's more of a guy thing like we
just know like if you smash them oh okay
not like you first might be saying like
in general if you know that someone like
you smashed then
okay
is that is that not more of a
is that not more of a reflection of your
male friends though what what you think
of your male friends as opposed to the
girl if you're kind of saying if you've
smashed him
like
do you know what i mean
is that yeah is that is that norm not
more of a reflection of what you think
of the guy than the girl
yeah but there's also like there's
levels in it like
there's levels too and
you can say reflection of this person
and that person but end of the day and
if you're a hoe
you just know from both sides that you
are heard
in the fine words of cardi b a hoe never
gets cold
this is my like saying there's like a
whole study that was released about this
recently which was but hoes don't get
caught so like geordie girls up north in
newcastle renowned for going out in kind
of minus degree weather in the shortest
skirts at the highest hills yeah no
coats but somehow they're absolutely
fine don't get cold every southerner
would be like
and so there's someone did a whole study
about cardi b in this song saying uh
that hoes never get cold you know they
can always wear like minimal clothing
right and they don't get cold they're
fine they're doing their thing
um someone did a whole like masters or
phd thesis or whatever okay but yeah so
so kit what is your definition about how
do you call women house you kind of
strike me as a guy that wouldn't
i don't call women highs horace
okay you know like people are
promiscuous okay
what jordan peterson would say
um
but by definition of you know the slang
of what we would call a quote quote i
think if a girl if a girl
has
quote unquote got around i think she's
going around like a friendship group
then to that group she's going to be
seen as that she's going to be seen as
that do you know what i mean because
it's one thing to
it's one thing to get around but then
if everybody knows and you're still just
acting that way
then
you don't
if you then you're not fussed about your
reputation in that sense because you
because the reality is you know that
it's gonna play a part
do you know what i mean yeah so
if you know that your reputation
if you don't care about your reputation
and you're just gonna do you which is
fine each to their own
but then people are going to call you
what it is do not mean that's true yeah
yeah i kind of i kind of feel like it
depends on the motive
um behind it so
like they could be
subject a and b
one
could have slept with 20 and uh the
second person i slept with 20 as well
but the way the first person must have
done it like
she could have just been gassed up by
her friends and said you know what let
me just go on mad one tonight and just
just run through 10 people at once or
sorry
bro or the second person
like
they fell for one put like
they weren't too smart in relation so
they liked one guy and then thought he
was going to treat her nice got [ __ ]
over yeah it's another guy got [ __ ]
over but the thing is her mercy behind
it wasn't to be a whole like to run
around it just happened sort of thing so
i feel like it depends on the motive
interesting
okay so
for the women
yeah
do you do you think does sexual past
matter to you in a guy the sexual past
so oh like would it
like if a guy had slept with a hundred
girls before he met you do you care
no
couldn't can i swear on this by the way
yeah you can swallow oh great because i
give a [ __ ] yeah literally couldn't care
less yeah i don't it's not a thing for
me i don't care especially i think if
we're talking numbers i feel like people
view sexual past
really
quantitatively
really in terms of numbers and things i
don't think that's a reflection at all
of what kind of a partner you are
sexually or otherwise
i've slept with people who have slept
with loads of people who were [ __ ] in
bed i've slept with people who've slept
with minimal people and it worked well
in bed we were great whatever we had a
good relationship
so i think in terms of the quality of
the relationship you have with them
whether it's a fleeting relationship or
a lasting one i like
yeah it doesn't matter for me it's more
about how someone treats people yeah
to me there's a number where it's kind
of okay
i was having this conversation if you
slept with anyone in my family cooked
any of my sisters
i feel like that's weird
close friends cooked
close like immediate front cooked
so just anyone that you know no but i
don't here's the thing i don't have that
many friends
there's like three people you cannot
sleep with
[Laughter]
um
please don't [ __ ] my mom
um but i don't know like i guess if it's
extreme like if i did i you can't say
you say corn instead of okay but if i
got a corn cooked like that so like to
the extreme but for the most part like i
don't really care
but it's interesting so i'm gonna ask
the guys the same question
what was the sexual past with the girl
does it matter to you
yeah you start
so sexual past in sense of if we're in
london
and
all right because we're in eastern i use
iceland and there's eight guys i know in
east london i've been with
it's game over like
yeah so that sort of passed but if if i
never knew what it did in the past and
you just came and no one knows you i
could really care careless
okay when i was yeah yeah you want to
feel like you you found her yeah you
don't want to
have a goal that you know everyone has
had because then like the value of it
goes away like you don't want to treat
her the same because you know like yeah
and she
she like she gave her up easy for the
next man and it's like well you're a
[ __ ] in it like you're spending this
amount of money this amount of time yeah
and you could have done less and got the
same thing yeah so
yeah
and that's the interesting thing like i
think guys care a lot more about that
than girls